foreign
I've been asked to respond on behalf of
my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister who is currently attending the
G20 leaders Summit in Bali may also say
Mr Speaker after the missile strike in
Poland yesterday that we reaffirm our
solidarity with Poland we express our
condolences with the victims and we're
working with our allies to determine
precisely what happened and the foreign
secretary were making a statement
shortly I bet
Mr Speaker could I begin by associating
myself with the comments of adaptive
prime minister I'm sure the whole house
will want to reaffirm our complete
support for Ukraine and for Poland in
the face of Russian aggression
when he had got the job in his first day
the Prime Minister promised and I quote
Integrity professionalism and
accountability where is it I assume the
Deputy Prime Minister agrees with that
promise and would expect all ministers
to follow such principles therefore does
the Prime Minister Deputy Prime Minister
also agree
that in line with this promise
the Prime Minister should ensure that no
Minister who has a complaint of bullying
opailed upheld against them should
continue to serve in his government
can I Thank The Honorable gentleman and
thank him for his shared solidarity on
the issue in Poland he's right to quote
what the Prime Minister said and I take
it as an article of personal faith that
we behave with absolute integrity and
accountability
I am confident that I have behaved
professionally throughout but
immediately I heard that two complaints
had been made I believe they were made
yesterday I was notified this morning I
immediately asked the prime minister to
set up an independent investigation and
of course I will comply with it fully
Corrections
last week many of my constituents are
celebrating with Guru nanak Dev ji who
traveled the world with an important
message about equality and sever
selfless service it's something we see
running through many of the actions
carried out by Sikhs and others in my
constituency of West Bromwich East
through organizations like Midlands
langa service society and Guru harai
gudwara with my right honorable friend
join me in thanking the community for
their ongoing Sever and extend his best
wishes for gerparab the Deputy Prime
Minister can I thank our honorable
friend that this important time of year
for the Sikh community in the seek faith
I join with her and what she said they
make an outstanding seat Community make
an outstanding contribution
in her constituency with the Midland
Langer server society and the guru Hari
Gurdwara in her constituency but they
also make an amazing contribution uh to
the whole country and we're grateful for
it Deputy leader Angela Reyna
thank you Mr Speaker and can I share the
Deputy Prime Minister of remarks
regarding the Sikh community and most
importantly about the incident in Poland
last night I know the whole house stands
United in our support for the Ukrainian
people and sends condolences for the
tragic loss of life and Britain has an
unshakable commitment to Nato and our
allies including Poland the government
has rightly requested we establish the
facts and avoid unhelpful speculation so
I understand that the Deputy Prime
Minister might not be able to go further
today but does he agree that last
night's events aside the fact that
Russia is launching missile attacks on
Ukrainian civilian infrastructure whilst
world leaders meet she also utter
contempt that Putin has for
international order
can I thank uh right on the lady I
entirely agree with what she said
President Putin started this war and
whatever the determination made in
relation to the events yesterday they
result whether directly or indirectly
from the unlawful aggression perpetrated
by the Russian government and that's why
the prime minister is out at the G20
rallying support making sure we wean
ourselves of energy uh dependence on
Russia making sure we make sure we've
got the energy Supply from other parts
of the world and and I agree with what
she said 100 Angela Ray
uh thank you Mr Speaker and it's right
that we condemn Putin in his strongest
terms but the G20 is also an opportunity
to work together to tackle the economic
challenges we all face yet as our
International allies race to crack down
on multinationals using tax Havens to
statch profits abroad this government is
dragging its feet to protect their
profit we have a budget tomorrow Mr
Speaker where it's brief that tough
choices will be impacting on families
across Britain does he accept that every
pound hidden in tax Havens is a pound
loss from the pockets of Working
Families
[Applause]
look we want people to come to this
country to create the jobs uh and to
generate the tax revenue uh whether it's
non-dom status which was stricter under
this government given the changes we
made than under the last Labor
government whether it's the prime
minister's approach to Big tech
companies where he's led the charge with
the G presidency in making sure there's
an international approach and delivering
a global minimum corporate tax rules we
have lowered the tax Gap the difference
between the tax owed and the tax uh
raised to the lowest level certainly
lower than on the last Labor government
and will continue to do so
I know it's namdon status hasn't been
abolished though Mr Speaker and the
conservatives the conservatives with
habazar believe that the economic
problems are out of their hands when the
truth is Mr Speaker it's working people
paying the price for their choices
they've chosen to protect corporate
profits and not household incomes there
are 38 countries in the OC oecd two-year
growth League table where does the UK
rank in that table
[Music]
she'll know that on the latest data
unemployment remains at a 50-year low
[Applause]
's Chancellor is saying it's gone up
it's half the level left by the last
Lady
[Applause]
and when it comes
and when it comes to GDP she'll know
that the IMF has said that we will have
the strongest growth in the G7
Mr Speaker I think the economic
situation families face speaks for
itself but I'll answer the question for
the Deputy Prime Minister the answer is
38 out of 38 on growth if there was a
World Cup for growth we wouldn't even
qualify working people are paying the
price for 12 years of Tory failure the
wrong choices by the wrong people now
after days of dodging and denial
this morning the Deputy Prime Minister
finally acknowledged formal complaints
about his misconduct but his letter
contains no hint of admission or apology
this is anti-bullying
this this is anti-bullying week will he
apologize
[Applause]
in terms of the economic challenges
which are Global caused by covert and
the war in Ukraine we've got a plan to
grip inflation balance the books and
drive economic growth if we listen to
The Honorable lady debt would go up
unemployment would go up and working
Britains would pay the price she asked
she asked she asked about the complaints
I received notification this morning I
immediately asked the Prime Minister set
up an independent uh inquiry into them
I'm confident I pay professionally
throughout but of course I will engage
thoroughly and look forward Mr Speaker
may I say look forward to transparently
addressing any claims that have been
made
[Applause]
an investigation into himself because
the prime minister is too weak to get a
grip yeah prime minister in office less
than a month with a disgrace cabinet
minister resigned with his good wishes
the Home Secretary who breached the
ministerial code and written National
Security still clings on and now the
Prime Minister defends his Deputy whose
Behavior has been described as abrasive
controlling and demeaning with junior
staff Mr Speaker too scared to even
enter his office and that's without
mentioning the flying Tomatoes the
Deputy Prime Minister knows his behavior
is unacceptable so what's he still doing
here
every prime minister Mr Speaker I'm here
and happy to address any specific point
she wishes to make uh that that well
that never happened uh she says from a
sedentary position and I will thoroughly
rebut and refute any of the claims that
be made she hasn't in fact she hasn't in
fact put a specific point to me if she
wishes to do so and this is her
opportunity I'd be very glad to address
it Angela Rayner
Mr speaker
thank you Angela wren thank you Mr
Speaker maybe he just doesn't think
there's a problem or maybe suggesting
that civil servants are liars
now he's reportedly banned from meeting
junior staff without supervision while
we await and inquiry the Prime Minister
hasn't even instigated from a watchdog
he hasn't even appointed in a prime
minister's letter he did not say how and
when this will be investigated or by who
no ethics no integrity and no mandate
and still no ethics advisor so when will
they appoint an independent ethics
advisor and drain the swamp
memory prime minister Mr Speaker the
recruitment of the new ethics advisor is
already underway and taking and taking
place at place but may I say Mr Speaker
there's a reason that she's come to this
Matchbox with her usual mix of Bluster
and mudslinging is because they don't
have a plan
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we're helping people into
work she's in hook to the unions we're
protecting our borders she voted against
every single measure to control illegal
immigration for this country we're
delivering cleaner growth and energy
security she wants to send billions in
reparation payments abroad the British
people want a government they can deal
with the real challenges and they're not
up to it
work
thank you Mr Speaker Hope House
children's hospice provides dedicated
end-of-life care to children from
Telford and across Shropshire this
Sunday hope house is holding an online
fundraiser called the big night Inn and
they aim to beat last year's Target of
half a million pounds Among The Fabulous
prizes are premium tickets to the
Telford steam Railway Polar Express
[Music]
[Applause]
you welcome a Christmas adventure to the
North Pole complete with hot chocolate
cookies gold and tickets and the first
gift of Christmas from Santa which is
the reindeer Silver Bell
please will the Deputy Prime Minister
log on to Hope House children's hospice
big night Inn this Sunday and if he's
lucky enough to win a pair of tickets to
the Telford Polar Express I should be
delighted to go to the North Pole with
him
[Applause]
can I thank my honorable friend and
congratulate her and Hope House
children's hospice for the amazing work
they do I've been working very closely
with shooting star child hospices which
is a similar organization in my
constituency if she ever gets bored of
the trains I jumped out of an airplane
at 15 000 feet to raise money for
shooting star she's a she'd find a
thoroughly enjoyable experience
leader of the SMP Kirsten Oswald thank
you Mr Speaker and can I associate
myself and my colleagues with the
remarks made about the immense
contribution of our Sikh communities Mr
Speaker the SNP extend our full support
and condolences this morning to Poland
following the death of two civilians
last night and while a full
investigation is ongoing we reiterate
our calls for Russia to end its brutal
war overgression against Ukraine Mr
Speaker yesterday the Prime Minister was
asked six different times to apologize
for the disaster of the Tory mini budget
and the financial crisis it caused
and all six times he refused to say
sorry
and now this morning people are waking
up to the news that this Christmas they
will be hit with the worst inflation in
41 years so will the Deputy Prime
Minister stand up today and do what his
boss wouldn't will he say sorry
Minister can I thank you honorable lady
for what she said both about Poland but
also about the importance of our
solidarity of the International
Community against the appalling illegal
Invasion uh uh by Russia of Ukraine look
in terms of inflation uh clearly that is
a problem I think as Chancellor
announced prime minister and for months
uh it has been this prime minister has
been uh making clear that it is the
number one economic challenge we Face
we've got a plan to grip inflation to
balance the books to drive economic
growth and the my right honorable friend
of the chance will be making a statement
tomorrow the Autumn statement which will
set out our plan to take the Scottish
people and everyone across the United
king them through these challenges well
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if they
can't even say sorry for the mess that
they've made hope have of them fixed
because let's be clear tomorrow's budget
is imposing austerity 2.0 on all of our
constituents yeah yeah that is the
political choice that the Tories are
making but there are always different
and better choices
only this week the Scottish child's
payment Rose to 25 pounds a week that's
a 150 increase in eight months and it
will help 400 000 children
so if the Tories won't say sorry for the
mess that they have made will they at
least make the right choice for once
will his government join the fight
against child poverty tomorrow follow
the leads of the Scottish government and
match the Scottish child payments then
the Prime Minister The Honorable lady
will know that we are facing challenges
that are faced all around the world
because of Kobe because of the war in
Ukraine we've seen Rising inflation in
Germany in the Eurozone in the U.S but
the reality is this prime minister and
this Chancellor have a plan we're going
to have more details set out the Autumn
statement but of course the UK
government will continue to work with
the Scottish government collaboratively
to safeguard and protect the most
vulnerability the most the most
vulnerable right across the United
Kingdom and I think that's what the
Scottish people expect
are in a state of disrepair the
community is hugely worried about their
future it matters not just for my
constituents but for the whole country
because Mills are part of the UNESCO
world heritage site in the UK If
appropriate Redevelopment is not agreed
soon the site risks losing its world
heritage site status will my right
honorable friend confirm that government
will pay close attention to this case in
order to ensure that we do not lose our
world heritage status and will he come
with me to visit the mill and discuss
potential Solutions with local people
prime minister can I thank my honorable
friend for her campaigning on this and
yes of course we will continue to
monitor uh the the condition of belka
Mills and the planning applications I
think the best I can say is we strongly
encourage all the local bodies whether
it's the council the applicant to
continue to work together because of all
her constituents will to continue to
celebrate the proud and Rich tradition
represented by belper so Jeff Lou
Donaldson
Deputy Prime Minister will join me in
welcoming the comments Yesterday by the
foreign secretary to the European
scrutiny committee that securing
Northern Ireland's place within the
union will be the priority of the
government in the negotiations with the
European Union on the Northern Ireland
protocol one of the benefits of that
Union is the support that the government
of the United Kingdom is providing to
households and businesses across the
entire country to tackle the cost of
living crisis will the Deputy Prime
Minister assure me that the 400 pounds
energy support payment that is due to be
made to households in Northern Ireland
will be announced as soon as possible
Deputy Prime Minister yeah I thank uh uh
The Honorable gentleman uh absolutely
what he said about uh securing Northern
Ireland within the Constitutional
economic Integrity of the UK is
absolutely vital uh the Prime Minister
has been very clear up on that as well
as the foreign secretary and of course
the charts will be saying more uh on the
economic measures and the particular
fiscal measures he made uh he referred
to tomorrow so rapidly
even if an illegal migrant is stopped on
a French Beach as no one has ever
arrested he will simply come back the
next day will the Deputy Prime Minister
ensure that we remove all pulled factors
for illegal Migration by using his new
Bill of Rights to ensure that we have
the legal power to arrest and Deport and
detain illegal migrants and for instance
have a review about a national identity
card so that people just don't vanish
and they never ever get deported
[Music]
can I thank my honorable friends I
totally agree with him that we need to
strain every sinew to to stop this
appalling trade in misery there's no
Silver Bullet I think the uh the
agreement that the Home Secretary made
with her French opposite number will
help uh we're embedding UK officials
with their French counterparts for the
first time uh he's right that the Bill
of Rights can help as well uh not least
in preventing interim orders from the
Strasbourg Court from being recognized
in the UK courts uh on ID cards uh we
already have e-visas for people coming
to visit and live in the UK and they act
as digital evidence of someone else's
immigration status the one thing that's
clear though and I say to honorable
friends we'll have to do all of these
things in the teeth of the opposition
from the front bench opposite
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker our small rural
schools in yfa's particular difficulties
the head teacher at schoolton and
caldervale primary schools told me that
budgets in schools like ours has
stretched as we have to pay for a lot of
additional services but larger Urban
schools provide in-house she has to hire
the village hall for PE lessons because
the schools have no Hall she has to hire
taxes to bring in the school meals
because the schools have got no kitchen
so given the school budget cuts what
would the Deputy Prime Minister advise
my head teacher cuts from our local
children
Minister can I say to The Honorable lady
we are very sympathetic to the
challenges that all of our schools face
more will be said about the specific
measures tomorrow but she should stand
uh assured that we are the top Spenders
as a percentage of GDP and the G7 on
primary and secondary education and
standards which matter to pupils and
parents most have increased with Schools
rated good or outstanding up from 68 in
2010 to 87 today Kevin Foster thank you
Mr Speaker the Deputy Prime Minister
will be aware of the opportunities but
also the challenges facing tour Bays
tourism and Hospitality sector including
increased energy costs and the impact of
business rates what consideration is he
giving to the situation of torbay's
iconic industry and further measures to
support it
he's a fantastic Champion for tall Bay
now of course the chancellor will make a
statement uh tomorrow
um I can't speculate on the spending
decisions but he will have already
noticed the tourism recovery plan which
will help uh recovering from the
pandemic but also as part of the wider
leveling up agenda
Private Ryan
are completely out of control and since
the government broke the economy and
broke the mortgage Market the hope of
owning a home is quickly receding with
the cost of living skyrocketing Tory tax
Rises through the roof and an extra one
million people in the private rented
sector since 2010 will the government
get a grip and Tackle housing in my
constituency and across the country
the current honorable lady as a former
housing Minister I know how important
these issues are and I and I can also
and I can also tell the honorable lady
that the housing sector is looking at
the situation of renters and landlords
very carefully and legislation is coming
forward to shortly
thank you Mr Speaker my constituent
Mikey Acres who has verbal dyspraxia
said the following a few weeks ago I'm
not ashamed of my disability but I am
ashamed of the people who judge me
without knowledge or understanding five
percent of all children are impacted by
speech and communication needs according
to the Royal College of speech and
language therapists and the dyspraxia
foundation and more needs to be done to
raise awareness in society will my
writing will friend agree to convene a
meeting with the prime minister to raise
awareness about verbal dyspraxia so
inspirational people I make Mikey are
never again left without a voice
prime minister can I thank my honorable
friend for his doubty championing and
highlighting of Mikey's campaigning all
children and young people should need
should receive the support they need to
make the very best of all their talents
and potential we published he will know
a green paper in March covering a whole
range of these issues and I will
certainly make sure he gets a meeting
with the relevant minister
thank you Mr Speaker can protective
prime minister tell this house if he has
ever entered into a non-disclosure
agreement connected to a complaint
against him
foreign
[Applause]
to an employment dispute that was
settled in before I entered the house it
wasn't an NDA but it did involve a
confidentiality cause which was standard
at the time
thank you Mr Speaker and all our
constituents want to see an end to the
dangerous and illegal Crossings of the
channel and one of the best ways to do
that is to make sure that services are
delivered in the first safe place that
refugees flee to and in that context the
Deputy Prime Minister as a former
foreign secretary and development
Minister would he commit to backing the
work of Education cannot wait which
delivers education in those refugee
camps the Prime Minister well I kind of
thank uh my honorable friend she's
absolutely right about the brilliant
work they do she'll know how important
the campaign for a girl's education was
both the last prime minister also this
prime minister and we will certainly
look at what more we can do to support
the brilliant worker particularly for
children growing up in camps like that
Dr Robert thank you Mr Speaker
which I congratulate him on and the new
direction of Tomorrow signaled that the
ban on novel evictions from the last
Manifesto is all back on after zilch
from the last pm and if so can he buy
emergency Powers if necessary get it on
the statute book so no family on a whim
gets left out in the cold this winter
I know my right honorable friend the
housing sector is looking at all of
these matters he would have heard what
she said and I won't Prejudice what what
further measures he's going to come
forward with but I will ask him to write
to you to address the specific proposals
you're making Jake and blueswalk yeah Mr
Speaker
I wonder if my right honorable and
learned friend has noticed that the
people who are currently criticizing him
no thank you who are currently
criticizing him have a record of
bullying second to none
a labor a labor Member of Parliament
left Parliament because of anti-Semitic
bullying a distinguished BBC journalist
needed bodyguards at labor party
conferences and a current member of the
labor party officer right honorable
member was suspended from the service of
this house for bullying does he think as
I do that this is at the very least
hypocritical and maybe a stronger word
that is not necessarily parliamentary
[Applause]
my my right honorable friend uh makes
this point in his usual inimitable way
uh all I will say is I think it's
important that we all take
responsibility for our actions and
that's precisely what I've done today
it's regularly from exposed veterans
during nuclear weapons tests however
I've been made aware that many veterans
and their families have reported being
unable to obtain these test results and
so denied the ability to make any sense
of what they and in some cases their
families suffered so can the secretary
investigate and inform me of the legal
rights of these men in obtaining their
medical records and will he undertake to
ask the prime minister to order these
medical files be open to Veterans and
the UK Health Security Agency
immediately Deputy Prime Minister okay
thank God lady
um she's been a a consistent champion on
this issue and I recognize and pay
tribute to her for that my understanding
is that the information is available to
Veterans and their families who may
request details of their service and
medical records but if she would like to
write to me I will make sure on the more
specific points she made she gets an
advocate answer hey
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise not to
perpetuate pastors and shipment or
parrot party lines but merely to amplify
the sentiments of the right of the
honorable honorable honorable lady and
for Salford and Eckland Eccles uh the uh
Brave servicemen who did so much so long
ago to ensure our safety the nuclear
test veterans were recognized by former
Prime Minister David Cameron and in a
meeting with the honorable lady and I by
the former prime minister the member for
Oxbridge well this Deputy Prime Minister
and our new prime minister recognize
them too not only by doing what the
honorable lady has asked for but by
giving them the service medal they so
richly deserve and we owe them
my right or my friend is absolutely
right and we should forever be grateful
uh to all those service Personnel who
participated in the British nuclear
testing program ground I can tell him
that I can reassure him we have asked
officials to look again at recognition
with medals and any recommendations will
be announced in the usual way Juliet's
coming
thank you Mr Speaker seven years ago in
my first pmqs a conservative prime
minister told me to stop griping and get
behind his rail investment plans a few
weeks ago the new business secretary
said there really wasn't much point in
going ahead with Northern Powerhouse
rail time and time again Mr Speaker tari
prime ministers have promised NPR only
to break their promises so will the
Deputy Prime Minister Now put on record
whether he supports transport for the
North's preferred option for NPR with
the stop in Bradford
of the Prime Minister I can tell the
honorable lady that our 96 billion pound
integrated rail plan will make the
northern Powerhouse rail a reality we're
committed with we're committed to the
project the nice details will be set out
in due course Peterborough
cut
who crossed the channel from France
illegally were immediately returned to
France it would stop illegal migration
in this country it would break the
economic model of the people's mothers
let's do it and perhaps more importantly
it would stop thousands and thousands of
people descending to Northern French
cities which would be to the benefit of
the French so Mr Speaker when the Prime
Minister spoke the French president was
a returns policy discussed and if so
what was the Prime Minister what was the
president's response
he's absolutely right to raise this
issue I can't tell him the precise
readout from the meeting I haven't seen
it yet what I can tell him is of course
the home secretaries deal an agreement
with her French opposite number means a
40 increase in officers patrolling
beaches in northern France for the first
time ever UK officers will be embedded
with their French counterparts there'll
be investment in Port security
infrastructure more technology and more
wider European Corporation we have taken
all of these measures and all in the
teeth of the opposition of the front
bench opposite they've opposed every
single measure that we've taken to stop
illegal immigration including things
where you'd think there was cross-party
consensus like life sentences for those
traffickers that prey on human misery
Master speaker it's not trade unions
have fun public services to the ground
it's the Tories it was not Asylum
Seekers fleeing war and famine heard
inflaming tensions at the Tories and
it's not those and more paid jobs her
trashing the economy again hits the 20th
can the Deputy Prime Minister inform the
house when the story government will
finally accept responsibility for their
economic social and political
mismanagement rather than blaming
everyone else
thank you prime minister well Mr Speaker
it's not a matter of blaming anyone it's
a matter of the team effort the shared
Endeavor working with the Scottish
government to make sure we get a grip on
inflation the number one priority and
it's got to be said uh if you uh if she
takes the honorable lady takes the
position that we agree with
inflation-busting pay Rises as difficult
as these decisions are we will only see
inflation stay and prolong for longer
that will hurt the most vulnerable in
our in our communities whether it's in
Scotland or across the rest of the UK
Anderson it is
we have a brilliant Home Secretary but
the Deputy Prime Minister will be aware
of a wicked ambitious bullying campaign
led by the opposition to get a sight
over the past four weeks or so so can
the Deputy Prime Minister please
reassure me and the people of Ashfield
that the Home Secretary will be given
all the tools that she need to solve the
migrant crisis and keep the bully boys
after number 10.
my little friend is absolutely right we
fully support the Home Secretary and the
important measures she's taking uh
whether it's uh the Lander scheme
whether it's implementing the
nationality and borders uh act and
whether it's the new deal with France to
make sure that we collaborate with our
International Partners on what is a
shared issue and the one thing that he
can also rest assured is it will be
opposed tooth and nail by the labor
party opposite Charles Paul
thank you Mr Speaker in 1936 people from
my constituency in jarrow marched to
Parliament demanding jobs they were
living in poverty and were hungry 86
years later and 39 of kids in javo are
still hungry so will the Deputy Prime
Minister and his government end this
Scandal and commit to providing free
School meals to all 800 000 children 40
000 of them in the Northeast to
households in the seat of Universal
Credit yeah the Prime Minister can I
Thank The Honorable ladies you'll know
that we've extended the eligibility of
free School meals to 1.9 million pupils
there's also on top of that the 200
million pound holiday activities and
food program and then 1 200 pounds of
direct payments to the most vulnerable
but I would just gently say to her we
also need to keep an eye on the Mac work
economic picture the number one priority
is to get inflation down and we won't be
able to do that if we follow the plans
of the benches opposite Esther mcvick
speaker
given that we have the highest burden of
Taxation in living memory it is clear
that the government's financial
difficulties are caused by overspending
and not due to under taxing does the
Deputy Prime Minister therefore agree if
the government has got enough money to
proceed with hs2 at any cost then it has
sufficient money not to increase taxes
if however it has so little money it has
to increase taxes which is a last thing
for a conservative government to do then
it doesn't have sufficient money for hs2
so can I gently urge the Deputy Prime
Minister not to ask conservative MPS to
support any tax Rises unless and until
this unnecessary vanity project is
scrapped because I for one won't support
them
can I thank my right honorable friend I
I think I followed the various steps of
logic in that question
um I I understand Herald positioned uh
to hs2 I think we've got some very
difficult decisions to make they will
inevitably involve a balanced approach
uh I will leave it to the chancellor to
set them out in the Autumn statement
tomorrow David
Mr Speaker in
eight months is run by the BET Russell
trust and they've issued over 2 000 food
Parcels during the last six months and
there's a question from the users of
that food bank it is will the government
give a firm commitment to ensuring but
benefits will always be enough to
purchase Essentials
he raises a really important point and
uh we're doing everything we can to
support those uh who may be reliant on
food banks or otherwise uh struggling to
make ends meet he can see that the
honorable friend can see that with the 1
200 pounds cost of living support that
going to the 8 million most vulnerable
households with the energy price
guarantee and further measures for
pensioners my right humble friend the
chancellor will set out further measures
tomorrow but of course as I said before
the number one priority is getting
inflation down we won't be able to do
that if we follow the spending plans of
the party opposite final question
thank you Mr Speaker my right humble
friend is also the Justice secretary and
everybody in this house irrespective of
party will know for the reputation of
this house that standards are important
he has said that from The Savage folks
this afternoon am I naive however in
response to some of the points raised by
members opposite am I naive to still
believe in that good British tradition
that one is innocent until proven guilty
well he makes an important Point uh and
of course and I've said I will cooperate
fully with the independent investigation
in fact I welcome the opportunity to
address these uh complaints I I think
though it is important that we have zero
tolerance for any bullying and we hold
the highest standards in public life and
it's important on all of us to adhere to
those standards
okay right that completes prime
minister's questions
all right let's just start with the
Urgent quit
so John what are you doing we start why
do you go the other way
give him a job on that front bench right
let me start with you with your question
Yvette Cooper shall the secretary
Home Secretary to make a statement on
the migration
thank you Mr Speaker the continued rise
of dangerous Channel Crossings is
completely unacceptable this phenomenon
is not only a clear abuse of our
immigration laws and deeply unfair on
the British people but it puts the lives
of those who attempt these Journeys in
grave Danger
this government is determined to put the
people Smugglers out of business and to
make this route unviable this week my
writer or friend the Home Secretary met
her counterpart minister darmana to
agree a new multi-year strategic and
operational plan with France this will
be supported by UK investment of up to
72 million euros in 2022-23 it includes
a 40 uplift a uk-funded officers
patrolling the French Coast over the
come